salve e molto ma molto bello avere dei
fan a molti sono anni ormai che facevi
de c'è sempre più gente che mi segue io
preferisco chiamarlo pubblico perché un
po più amichevole ma molti di voi sono
fans e lo dico con tutto il bene
possibile ci mancherebbe e allora qual è
la differenza fra i fans e il pubblico
il pubblico e quello che guarda il tuo
lavoro e gli piace guardare il tuo
lavoro è tanti cari saluti il fan's
invece è molto più attaccato alla
persona piuttosto che al lavoro sono
quelli che magari chi vorrebbero
regalare qualcosa ad una fiera liberto
frigobar ora regge bene o questa magari
un po meno elaborata però il pensiero
conta tantissimo c'è scritto ti amo
tanto così e magari sarò un po materiale
come persona però io adoro i regali per
me come se fosse sempre natale e poi ci
sono quei fans talmente affezionati che
addirittura non si iscrivono più fans ma
si scrivono fruit e credo che non lo
facciano neanche apposta lo scrivono
proprio pensando che sia giusto così ma
non me ne frega niente li adoro
tantissimo e tra le decine e decine di
commenti messaggi che mi arrivano al
giorno
ogni tanto qualcuno mi fa notare alcune
cose che magari io mi sono lasciato
sfuggire come per esempio le fan fiction
per chi non sapesse cosa sono le fan
fiction nell'abisso sono delle fiction
fatte dai fan
no la decisione non è neanche tanto
lontano dalla lotta voglio dire sono
storie di finzione cioè fiction fatte
con personaggi reali e non tecnicamente
famosi non scritte dai fan e
recentemente ho scoperto che ce ne sono
alcune sugli youtuber e non avendo un
cazzo di meglio da fare nella mia vita
sono andato subito a fiondarvi per
cercare le vie devo trovarmi un
obiettivo nella vita avete ragione e ho
scoperto che esistono 45 fan fiction su
di me e siccome il mio cervello è ormai
completamente [ __ ] ho detto ne prendo
due o tre l inter
e quindi oggi siamo qui ad interpretare
le fan fiction dei fu il disclaimer io
queste cose le adoro per quindi vorrei
ringraziare personalmente chi ha scritto
queste fanfiction al ragazzi o ragazze
che hanno scritto queste function però
non vorrei fare più danno che altro
magari nominali quindi io le leggo se
voi li riconoscete chi ha scritto la fa
vince me lo dica che mettono le
informazioni i ringraziamenti con il
vostro nome
buona lettura fra fiction numero uno
youtube i down sono un ululato di
frustrazione proprio lì sulla sua
scrivania lucente come un gioiello
invitante come big bear c'era il nuovo
gioco di grand theft auto per ps3 ancora
nel pacchetto di plastica e lui non
potevo usarlo la ragione era molto
semplice non riusciva a trovare il
joystick da nessuna parte che tra
l'altro se proprio vogliamo fare i
[ __ ] joystick sarebbe la cloche
con cui si guidano i jet io trovi
impre.co mentalmente gettando all'aria
qualche decina di dvd di bear grylls ma
no solo da collezione quelli aveva
guardato sotto il letto sulla tv dietro
la tv in tutti i cassetti e quel
maledetto joystick non sembrava essere
da nessuna parte non si sentiva così
male dai tempi di alex l'ariete up
davvero ma dove dove continuò a
imprecare yotobi incurante del fatto che
nessuno eccezione fatta forse per il
peluche di mario che troneggiava sulla
sedia accanto alla scrivania sembrava
ascoltarlo troneggiano cose così che fa
mario quando non ci sono troneggia la
voce del gioco che lo chiamava lo
invitava a inserire il disco e
precipitare in un nuovo mondo era sempre
più sovente gli addobbi afferrò il
pupazzo di buzz lightyear che teneva
accanto al pc e uno scambio via
lanciando parolacce irripetibili contro
il joystick scomparso improvvisamente
una vocetta fastidiosa risveglio la sua
attenzione ma che stai facendo
vedi che i giusti che sul tuo letto io
dove al solo sguardo dai cassetti per
incontrare gli occhi fissi e incuranti
di sgorbio touches tornato maledicendosi
per avuto l'idea per aver avuto
maledicendosi per avuto l'idea balzana
di creare aspetta che lo con regole ed
era così il joystick il maledetto
joystick fuggitivo giaceva dimenticato
sul letto in mezzo a una pila di cuscini
e coperte ha già dovuto filippo dice
belometti di scortichino l'aprila di
cucine norme you tube afferrò
febbrilmente l'oggetto incriminato e
cominciò a strillare di gioia
saltellando con un leprotto diretti nel
frattempo dall'alto dello scaffale su
cui aveva messo dimora sgorbio alzo gli
occhi al cielo e poi quello strano sarei
io
bellissima bellissima anche solo l'idea
che io mi metta a cercare per tutta casa
senza votare che c'è una enorme montagna
di cuscini e mezzo al letto vi favorirà
siete fantastici questa è la seconda fan
fiction
forse mi conoscete già o forse no se
seguitelo youtuber gli automi tale
saprete che ogni tanto quando guardo un
film veramente brutto e deve sfogare la
sua rabbia su qualcosa
la povera vittima e il pupazzo di mario
e mario sono io il summer mario scusa
nessuno ha mai pensato alla mia
sofferenza
a nulla valgono le sue scuse tardive
sempre in ritardo e alla fine del video
non ha mai pensato che io possa soffrire
veramente loro lo so
ed è per questo che ti meno ogni volta
che guarda un film ho paura paura che se
la prenda con me che sfoga la sua rabbia
su di me
nessuno sa quanta paura ogni volta non
mi scorderò mai quella volta che guardo
un film veramente brutto
penso si chiamasse albachiara quella
volta mi picchiò selvaggiamente e lo
mise eppure nel vivo
si scusò solo dopo emise quel momento ad
inizio video ma non gli ha giovato per
niente non ho mai trovato rancore
nemmeno quella volta la mia paura non fa
che crescere
c'hai la strizza è recentemente ho
assunto due guardie del corpo
jake il link tra l'altro piccola
parentesi che non certa moto e io è che
lo giuro su dio un asse da stiro che un
gol identica a fine di adventure club
niente male avevo paura che potesse
succedere di nuovo
e avevo ragione dopo che ha guardato un
altro film
shark nadeau si è messo a cercarmi ma
appena ha visto gente link se n'è andato
ma mi ha lanciato una bruttissima
occhiata mela farà sicuramente pagare in
futuro
ho paura aiutatemi j che il link non ci
saranno per sempre
aiutatemi prima che sia troppo tardi ma
non è un thriller mi fai quasi stare
male per sto mario quasi tra l'altro
appunto parlando di regali quando sono
nato a napoli al comicon hanno trovato
il figlio di registico divario questa
fanfiction invece è stata presa e messa
su delle pagine facebook e dopo che è
stata presa e messa su queste basi e
facebook
l'autrice e barra autore la cancellata
dal sito delle fan fiction quindi io
leggo dall'immagine e chiedo scusa se
per caso si offenda l'autore ma perché
ovviamente la cancellata da lì però mi
sembrava una cosa molto carina e lo
faccio veramente con il cuore perché vi
ringrazio tantissimo per queste cose qua
io le adoro e questa è la fan fiction ed
è soltanto una parte di dialoghi tra me
e dario moccia
dario non ho più voglia di ideare
scrivere e parlare di mostarda scrisse
velocemente deja vu le 6 ott obi
sorridendo amaramente cosa vorresti fare
ora recensioni di nuovo dichiaro tv
andare a quel paese
ti manderei a quel paese
non so se ti manderei a quel paese
scherzo l'amico scrivi sulla tua pagina
che oggi non ci sarà mostarda e che
tornerai alle recensioni
quante volte ci aveva pensato però
qualcosa lo tratteneva sempre aveva
riflettuto a come i suoi fans e
l'avrebbero presa aveva riflettuto come
avrebbe raccolto quel cambio di
decisione non è così semplice commento
karim spazientito non l'hai fatto anche
la scorsa volta solo al contrario tuscia
la sua ultima nave si stava tenendo a
galla ma la pena allora farlo di nuovo
non ci vuole molto in fondo sono solo
cinque parole ma non lo so provò a
contestare karim muoviti
qui è il tuo amico più che amico dario
moccia che ti parla
[Musica]
vuoi farla con me questa nuova
recensione gli chiese un po troppo
speranzoso beh sì dai
a presto si mise offline è la cosa più
bella del è per questo che i fan perché
con niente riuscite a farvi ridere di
gusto e create queste cose fantastiche
che per me voglio dire tantissimo
vuol dire che ogni giorno apprezzate
lavoro che faccio in e sono
contentissimo e tra l'altro di questi
fan fiction ce ne sono un sacco solo che
non riesco a trovare per caso state
cancellate o solo in forno scuri
indipendenti gestite dalla gente in uno
scantinato buio per esempio ho trovato
una lista di titoli di fan fiction
immensa ma purtroppo solo solo i titoli
e non riesco a trovarle e non riesco a
trovare i testi interi però da quei
titoli devono essere delle cose
bellissime per esempio protagonisti gli
odori dario moccia che cosa stai facendo
[Musica]
daniele doesn't matter guglielmo scilla
dio topi allora questo porno l'autrice
autore che di questa fabbrica orme la
devi inviare in busta chiusa per la
dovete stampare buon in testa la voglio
leggere guglielmo scilla yotobi so bad
it's so cool anche il segnale comunque
io spero che con questo video non si sia
offeso nessuno è stato fatto per
dimostrare il vostro il mio affetto
verso di voi perché voi lo dimostrate a
me a noi anziano youtubers così io e io
sono favorevolissimo queste cose qua
perché mi fanno morire dal ridere ma non
nel senso che sono talmente stupida che
mi fanno male a volte sì quando lo fanno
apposta ma anche quelle fanfiction un po
più serie perché comunque le parti cio
non solo
robetta la maggior parte sono proprio
storie vere e proprio fatte con con cura
con con attenzione forse più quella su
mario che il secondo me l'inquietante e
quindi secondo me non c'è assolutamente
nulla di male in queste cose qua per il
letto
non si sia offeso nessuno l'ho fatto un
po per me un po per voi perché avere un
feedback del genere facendo
semplicemente il video imbecilli su
internet non è da poco
quindi grazie mille e ci vediamo ad un
po suo video stupido